Life has dealt me
some shitty cards,
but with this I'm about
to play a royal flush.
We're about to be
venture capitalists.
Mm-hmm (affirmative)-
On the south side.
Adventure capitalist?
Venture capitalists.
My way is better because you're
taking money on an adventure.
That's a nice little hustle.
Dude, he's selling popcorn.
Get the plug out of his butt.
I dab. I diggity dodge the jab
while wiggly liggity
loading up the cart
with popcorn bags.
We got popcorn
for a dollar.
And extra for some butta.
Alright, alright everybody
settle down.
Stacy please stop
popin' that gum.
Bruh, I'm gonna need you
to either pic
that afro all the way out,
or pat it all the way down.
I don't want to see it
in the middle. Okay?
That's a zaddy right there.
He is too cute.
Give me circle,
and I'll be right with you.
Okay? I got to get mines
and I gotta go get this dick.
Okay, officer. Go get that dick.
Let's do this.
With some cash.
My name is Keisha.
Yes I went to Kenwood.
Yes, I know Eddy Curry.
We used to go together.
Yes I have a son.
He is an elite
basketball player. Okay?
It says here in your paperwork
you have another son.
Yeah, he likes science.
Your
daddy's gonna get
a real good job
and he's gonna bring all of you
together in a big fancy house.
No more khakis on this block.
I don't trust niggas in khakis.
Write that shit down, Bluto.
The word is out.
You got no respect
for the law, do yeah?
No, I don't. I really don't.
You got me.
Okay, good. Good.
You were a very cavalier person.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, a cavalier person
[crosstalk 00:01:51]
Who, wait a [crosstalk
00:01:52].
Get down. Get down.
It's a beautiful day.
South side.
God is good. Somebody told me
I was gonna get you
a blessing this week.